we previously talked about after pay
which was bought by square for tens of
billions of dollars
and one of the interesting things about
after pay during that acquisition was
square was asked did you guys consider a
firm
which is another buy now pay later
platform and they said we didn't even
consider it
interesting well a firm was not going to
be left behind
by after pay a firm which max levchin
started
basically has said you know what we're
gonna go play with the big dogs
and amazon has now done a deal to enter
the buy now pay later space with a
partnership with a firm and so a firm's
checkout options will be available to
certain amazon customers starting a week
ago with broader rollout in the coming
months the partnership will let amazon
customers split purchases of 50 or more
into smaller monthly installments some
amazon customers loans will bear
interest but some will come with zero
percent apr amazon already has credit
card offers for prime members and cash
back incentives or introductory zero
interest terms through partnerships but
now a firm is in the game so a firm
stock has spiked as much as 48
on friday according after the news
adding more than eight billion dollars
to its market cap one partnership with
amazon 8 billion in market cap they work
with over 12 000 merchants including
peloton and walmart and if a firm
captures just one percent of amazon.com
north american sales it could add over
900 million dollars or 10 percent to its
revenue now as we previously discussed
buy now pay later is simply a modern
credit card to some degree if you think
of a credit card you basically walk into
the store you swipe a card when you
swipe that card you're using credit
and you pay off the card at a later date
remember free tip for everyone at home
your credit card is actually
reviewed by the credit agencies not when
your payment is due but usually a couple
days before make sure that you
continuously pay off your credit card
and you don't just pay it off once a
month when they tell you to that is a
way to boost your credit score but the
buy now pay later system essentially
does not use the terminology credit card
which has somewhat of a negative
connotation in younger people they think
that they've heard enough of credit
cards are bad people can get in credit
card debt the average credit card
balance in america is about six thousand
dollars the average credit card uh
interest rate is 16 17
and so it's a really really bad
situation if you use a credit card
incorrectly the beauty of buy now pay
later if you look at somebody like after
pay is they have no interest it's zero
percent interest loan but what they do
have is they have late penalties and so
i think after pays is 15
a firm has a different system here and
so when you start to look at the way
that we're watching credit
enter the young millennial generation or
those that are younger than maybe let's
say 35 years old or so is it is being
called buy now pay later it's not being
called a credit card when you look at
these systems it's also being integrated
directly into the platforms when you go
check out at the merchant you simply
click a button and you can break it up
into monthly installments so we have a
quote from eric morse the senior vp of
sales at a firm he said quote by
partnering with amazon we're bringing
the transparency predictability and
affordability that a firm provides today
to the millions of people who shop on
amazon.com in the u.s offering a firm's
alternative to credit cards also
delivers more of the payment choice and
flexibility consumers on amazon want and
quote
we can look and see a firm's revenue
sources when you look at this chart it's
pretty interesting because what it shows
is that the merchant network revenue
from retailers is 54 of a firm's revenue
their interest income off of the
consumer loans makes up 31
and then they basically have a couple of
other revenue sources but most of it
comes from the merchant network revenue
over 50
and then 30 or so comes from the
interest income from those loans
we then can look at the actual
websites with karna or after pay
installed remember we continue to see
this up a firm looks very very similar
is you saw from q1 of 2020 a just rapid
increase in the number of websites that
are deciding to do this the number of
platforms amazon is now in the game one
of the if not the largest retailer in
the world absolutely exploding you can
also see that not only are more people
installing it but the monthly visits to
these websites is taking off as well why
because more people are using this type
of mechanism this buy now pay later and
so then we can go in and we can look at
the percentages of people who used a buy
now pay later service so in july 2020
where are most of the folks using it
again
50 is in the 35 to 44 year old category
but still even surprising to me 42
of people in that 45 to 54 category have
used a buy now pay later service all the
way going back to july of 2020. if you
then look in march of 2021 an explosion
of interest we now have an 18 to 24 year
old category 61
penetration we have 60 across the board
up until you get to the age of 44 then
53 over 45 and over 55 40
so the smallest age bracket from a
percentage of those who have used buy
now pay later is 40 percent and those
are people over the age of 55. but the
youngest
demographic over 61 my guess is that we
will continue to see this rise in the
coming years and then we've got one more
chart here that our table i guess
that shows the interest rates and the
late fees so a firm they have interest
no late fees the interest rate is up to
30 depending on your credit worthiness
and the other types of products offered
zero percent apr may only be offered at
select merchants sounds a lot like a
credit card where you have an interest
rate that could be low or high
and there's no late fees but it's by now
pay later with interest after pay zero
percent interest rate up to 17 per lead
payment capped it up to 25 of your
initial order value or 68 whichever is
less future pay klarna paypal etc you
can see everyone's got a different model
but this is the future of where credit
is going in my opinion what credit card
do you know that offers zero percent apr
well
to be fair if let's say with the after
pay example right so zero percent
interest rate if i bought something for
uh let's say a hundred dollars and it
was split out among payments and i miss
two payments what ends up happening is i
pay 25
in late fees right i basically get
capped at the 25
but when that occurs
i basically am paying a 25 interest rate
which is higher than the average credit
card which is only 16 to 17
now the counter to that or the critique
of that argument is yes but the 16 17
percent average is every single year
until you pay off the whole thing
whereas this is capped at that 25 so you
could argue both ways that it's better
or worse yeah i think this is great um i
don't think it's going to replace credit
cards right so obviously the younger
demographic you said 60 have used it
since uh by the time in march of this
year uh but it's interesting because
credit cards offer points and cash back
and all those different things um and
i'm also curious why
why didn't amazon just do this
themselves like do they just they
outsource it because they need someone
else to use a service with or is it just
because they didn't want to deal with it
like they have the capital to fund
everything they
they could probably build the
infrastructure decently easily um so i'm
just curious why they didn't why didn't
they do themselves and outsourced it
it's a great question i don't have the
answer if i had to guess there's
probably two components one is
there's probably a high likelihood it's
easier to partner than build yourself
and then two is
amazon may not want to get into the game
of uh actually underwriting the loans um
having the capital base uh executing
that like building all the
infrastructure around the actual credit
component of it um amazon could do i
mean they could write software to do
whatever they want but it's almost one
of these things like
you can do something yourself and learn
from scratch you could go buy uh
somebody in the space or you could just
partner with somebody well it's not like
they're gonna take users from a firm
right and bring them to amazon it's more
going to be advice um a reversed um push
of customers right like people are going
to use a firm because now it's on amazon
if they get one percent of the north
american market share they're going to
increase their revenue by 10
that's insane they get 1 of amazon's
north american market share have either
have you ever done this buy now pay
later i've never done it no no uh i use
a credit card every day though right
so essentially you do it a little bit
well i use the kind of more traditional
legacy uh system rather than this but
i'm shocked to see 18 to 24 year olds 60
and then over 55 to see that uh they've
had over 40 percent of people have used
buy now pay later uh knowing how great a
penetration credit cards have yeah
honestly it's not really that surprising
to me because if you like any uh
basically ecommerce website you go to
now has it as an option and it's always
projected as like this super appealing
uh kind of payment option because of the
zero dollars down monthly payment
whatever and it's enticing for some
people obviously to be able to make
monthly payments rather than pay a
substantial portion upfront or feel like
they're paying it up front with a credit
card but yeah like i think uh we talked
about a firm last time when when square
made the big acquisition last month but
a firm when they went public they had 6
500 merchants that they were that were
using their product and a third of their
revenue came from peloton at the time so
they were massively concentrated with
one retailer and then if you look at
this deal like this is a game changer
for them from the perspective of like
not only are they not going to be
concentrated with one but they just
signed up an even bigger one right so
it's going to be massive from a revenue
standpoint but it's also going to
diversify their business with two major
players uh who are doing millions and
millions and millions of dollars of
revenue and billions of dollars of
revenue uh and we'll be there to expand
with them in the future well they had 6
500 merchants when they i guess ipo'd
right yeah they have over 12 000 now and
it's interesting because peloton
probably one of their biggest customers
just lost their prices on their bike
one of the things that's super
interesting to me
amazon as we talked about last week now
is going into physical retail stores
like department stores right so you
basically took an online uh bookstore
you blew it up it's the everything store
they are the number one e-commerce site
in the world uh or at least in north
america for sure and then you basically
go right back to the old model of now
they have start to have the physical
stores right yeah so uh
i wonder if the buy now pay later
platforms are going to end up actually
just issuing credit cards right to some
degree like do you basically just say
hey we have the customer base we have
millions of people we know that they
want credit cards as well as use these
buy now pay later services so we're just
going to go ahead and push into it um i
forgot who said in the comments as well
another um kind of perspective on this
is what you're seeing is a lot of these
retailers this is them dipping their
toes into financial services and
starting to understand and learn and see
the value of this and then what they'll
start to do is eat the stack right now
all of a sudden we've seen them in the
past if you went to a jcpenney or a
belk's or you know name your department
store that you would go to they would
always ask you if you wanted a jc penny
credit card or a belk or a macy's credit
card right and there was some kind of
you know gimmick or offer that came with
it uh same thing you see with like the
airlines when you go to check out an
airlines hey do you want the american
airlines credit card or whatever um
are we eventually just going to see this
start to permeate into all retailers
right in a world where shopify ends up
being incredibly important
infrastructure for people to be able to
have these online stores do we get a
world where they say hey now i can offer
credit to my customers i can use a firm
and i can basically extend buy now pay
later services to my customers of my
small business oh you know what actually
maybe i can white label and issue a
credit card to them as well like you
start to wonder about how this all plays
out but it just feels like these fintech
services have the tailwind at their back
and it's not going to stop any time soon
what's up guys bang bang a bunch of you
want to bring that trillionaire energy
every day and if you want to do it in
your financial life go use sofi sofa is
our exclusive sponsor because we think
they've got a great piece of software
that will help you accomplish your
financial dreams go to sofi.com today to
get started you can invest in everything
from etfs to individual stocks to
cryptocurrencies to ipos and they even
have an automated and best function head
on over to sofi.com
today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]
you